[Music]
hello and welcome everyone my name is
Florence gotu and I'm a product manager
here at Google I'm really excited to be
here today thank you for joining us for
this breakout session on defining
security guard rails uh with access and
organization
policies so what are security guard RS
on anyway well detection and Remediation
of security vulnerabilities or threats
is expensive and often too late to
prevent severe impact to your business
at Google Cloud we take prevention
seriously to help make this to help
customers make the shift towards a
preventative security posture we have
been investing in security controls that
allow administrators to establish
effective security guard rails that
protect your resources and data
today you will hear from box and snap on
how they establish and mature their
security guard rail
framework and while they share similar
security goals box and snap started
their Google Cloud Journey from
different points snap was one of the
first few gcp customers and their
security guard rail approach has
continuously evolved over time while box
has had the more recent migration to gcp
and which has given them a chance to
design the security guard rail from
scratch
despite their different history gcp
security guard rails were flexible
enough to allow both organizations to
establish a mature security guard rail
framework and meet their security goals
you'll hear more about this shortly but
first let's do a around of
introductions alongside me today we will
have Matt Bose senior staff security
architect at box we will also have Bach
bahaman a production security engineer
manager at snap and actually the a
product manager from Google cloud and
with that out of the way action I will
first cover a brief overview of gcp
security controls that can be used to
establish effective guard
rails starting off with why adopt this
type of approach in the first place as
an Enterprise continues to scale their
Cloud footprint it becomes very
difficult for a centralized Security
administrator team to rely on reactive
controls to enforce their security
posture without impacting developer
velocity in addition violation detection
and Remediation adds toil and cost
instead these security teams rely on
establishing a security guardwell
framework shifting their security
posture towards a preventative approach
this allows administrators to establish
a developer self-service model for
access management capabilities that is
in compliance with their organization
security requirements this model reduces
the burden of having to process access
management requests resource
configuration violations or other
similar security issues let's take a
look at some of these
controls and I'm as I'm sure you already
know IM am allow policies are
fundamental security controls that
allows administrators to manage access
controls for resources they own however
I am allow policies on their own to not
establish car rails to enable developer
Self Service nor do they shift the
security posture towards a preventative
approach instead I IM deny and
organization policies are the
fundamental Primitives for establishing
security guard rails on your resources
and
data now in order to adopt these
controls safely and at scale Google
Cloud also provides intelligent policy
life cycle management tooling that
simplify administrative operations
enable policy safe rollout and power
compliance reporting these tools
combined with these Primitives and
Google's machine learning capabilities
deliver a complete framework work to
allow administrators to establish an
effective security guard rail approach
let's cover each of these Primitives as
well as some of the policy life cycle
management tooling and more
debt and really the first layer in our
defense in- depth tool Suite is I am
deny which allows administrators to
explicitly deny access overriding any
existing or future IM allow policies IM
am denies a resource Centric control
which means the policy is attached to
the resource and once attached this
policy cap a list of permissions that
will always be denied when performed by
a set of given principles these
principles will never be able to perform
those actions on that resource even if
an IM IM allow policy Grant explicitly
allows access this can be used to enable
developer self-service and minimize the
amount of access management activities
by the centralized Security
administrator team this team can grant
developers wide access to their
environment and use I deny to prove
prune or set guard rails on the overall
permissions that can be executed within
this
environment for example imagine an
organization that is highly focused on
delivering machine learning models to
their
customers uh they probably have a quite
large data science and data engineering
department now these teams rely on
autonomy especially the developers and
the centralized security team could not
possibly keep up with all the access
change management requests or um other
security control changes without
impacting their velocity as an
organization instead the centralized
security team could Grant wide access to
the development environment and Define a
number of key IM IM deny policies that
prevent unauthorized actions for example
you could have a deny policy that
prevents his team from purchasing biery
commitments or from creating service
account keys in this example the team
was was able to control costs as well as
prevent unauthorized service account key
leak
while at the same time enabling
developer velocity within their
environment and giving them as much
flexibility as possible in the way they
operate now since I am Deni policies can
be applied at any level of the resource
hierarchy this is a very powerful
security control that you have in your
toolbox and in addition to preventing
actions on resources you will now hear
from AE who will talk about how to
enforce restrictions on resource
configurations
datar I'm a product manager here at
Google a key resource Centric layer is
organization policy or art policy which
allows you to control which resource
configurations are permitted in your
organization AR policy is a fundamental
native gcp control that uh allows you to
control your or protect your resources
um independent of principles or resource
actions and just like I am deny
administrators can apply this guardrail
at any layer or any level of the
resource hierarchy Arc policy service
inspects each and every at at
configuration time it inspects each and
every resource action and non-compliant
requests such as creating a
non-compliant resource configuration or
upd updating a resource to a
non-compliant state will get rejected
some really popular use cases for Arc
policies include restricting locations
where resources are permitted uh for you
know local uh local compliance reasons
uh restricting external traffic uh to
protect against breaches and exploits
and ensuring that you only use hardened
and trusted images for your
resources and and many many more there
are essentially two types of orc
policies that gcp offers first we have a
set of predefined pre-build uh orc
policies that we have identified based
on industry best practices um uh
feedback from customers such as
yourselves as well as red team findings
these are hardcoded and they are ready
to use for you second I am really
pleased to share the public preview
availability of customar policies for
gke GCE and and data proc with custom
Mark policies you can author really fine
grain tailored guard rails specific to
your unique security requirements using
uh easy to use easy to read common
expression language based logical
conditions um as an example consider a
use case where you have um you want to
ensure that only trusted images are used
for your gke uh applications and gke
workloads and only in certain sensitive
environments you can easily set up this
orc policy this custom orc policy using
the frame workor that I just described
and effectively you reduce the amount of
time needed to make policy changes down
to minutes and
hours now in order to safely adopt and
scale these guard rails in your
organization uh like Floren mentioned
gcp offers a suite of policy life cycle
management tooling uh we cover the
entire life cycle of your resources from
uh designing effective configurations to
deploying resources and detection as
well so recommendation tools like I am
recommender Leverage Google's ml
expertise to help you design an
effective security posture once this
posture is designed uh in order to
deploy it safely and securely uh we have
a set of tools that allow you to do that
as well as part of a safe deployment uh
tooling for one example is policy
simulator which allows admins to
understand the impact of policy and
posture changes on existing resources
similarly you can also set policy and
posture changes in dryon mode to
understand how they would behave uh in
the real world through audit logs
and finally gcp offers a robust set of
detection and troubleshooting tools uh
which help you monitor for example the
state of compliance using policy
analysis triage errors through trouble
shooting and identify drift through
violation uh reporting um now that we
have covered a few Basics about how we
approach security guard rates I would
love to invite Matt over to Showcase how
box uses um our controls for security
guard RA in Google
Cloud thanks
OE hi I'm Matt Bose of senior staff
security architect at box I came to box
about three years ago during the start
of our gcp migration my mission was to
build a secure foundation for gcp that
would allow us to migrate our on-prem
data center to the
cloud today I'm going to tell you about
box our security culture how we
Implement prescriptive security guard
rails and lastly what security features
we're excited about in gcp
a little about box box is a cloud
content management platform with almost
an exhibited data being stored shared
and collaborated on we have a customer
base of Fortune 500 companies government
entities and individual
users at box we are a uild it you ownit
culture we perform all production
changes via code and we have centralized
teams that control foundational services
such as networking project creation I am
and so
on the security goals that I'm going to
discuss are to implement prescriptive
security guard rails to follow the
principle of lease privilege and to
improve developer velocity by providing
feedback early in the development
process to accomplish our goals we take
a defense in-depth approach and apply
multiple security guard rails to our
organization today I'll discuss three of
these guard rails first we have or
policies then we'll talk about our lease
permissions model that we govern via IM
am policies and finally we'll talk about
our infrastructure as code policies
org policies are part of our secure
Foundation they allow us to establish
preventative guard rails to restrict
what actions can be taken they simplify
operations because they can be set once
at the root of the organization and
propagate out to all resources we
prioritized evaluating and implementing
or policies at the beginning of our gcp
journey to ensure that our
infrastructure was built securely from
the start our first priority with org
policies was to restrict Public Access
and to only allow box identities to be
out added to box am policies we didn't
apply every policy we selected the
policies that would help us meet our
requirements we manage all of our org
policies via code we store them in a
central location and one team is
responsible for org policy changes we
apply most policies at the org level and
they're inherited to all the the entire
environment and to provide a consistent
experience we try to keep the policies
the same in each
environment there are cases when
environments or projects will have
different policies one example is we
have an external IP constraint that
blocks uh public
IPS but we have specific networking
projects that need the ability to use
these public IPS for those projects
we'll set an exclusion and we'll allow
them to provision public IPS this allows
us to reduce the risk of exposing our
workloads to the internet except for the
exact workloads that need
it next I'll talk about our IM IM
policies our these permissions model
which is governed by IM IM policies is a
core Concept in our security strategy
when we decided to move to gcp we had to
figure out how to implement a lease
permission process we had the time to
design and and plan this uh process
before we were moving our workloads to
gcp here's how we do it first we don't
use any of the basic roles which are
owner editor and viewer these roles are
too powerful they Grant access to any
service in gcp and they will not meet
our
requirements we also do not rely on the
predefined roles even though they are in
what they can do they still have more
permissions than what's actually
necessary instead we create custom roles
with custom roles we can define a small
granular set of
permissions since we aren't using the
basic roles or any of the custom roles
or the predefined roles we needed a way
to allow access to specific gcp
services to do this we create a custom
developer role this role is curated by
us and includes permissions to all the
common gcp Services we use at box we
Grant this role to use users and service
accounts in our development environment
it gives developers the freedom to
create resources and develop their
application but this role itself does
not meet our lease permissions
requirement so how do we go from this
developer role to a role that will meet
our
requirements we do this by quaring the
am and insight the am insights and
recommendations API that gcp provides
the I am recommender tool gives us an
exact list of permissions that have been
used by a specific identity we analyze
those permissions then we create a
unique custom role on based only on the
permissions that were used we then
replace the developer role with this
unique custom role that was tailored
specifically for that
identity we don't want to have to go
through this process for for repeatable
patterns for those scenarios we've
created custom roles for services that
are commonly used for example we have a
custom rle for compute engine that only
includes basic permissions like the
ability to log to Cloud logging if a
team needs a standard VM they can
request this role and they will already
meet our
requirements
this process has allowed us to reduce
permissions on average by about 99% when
compared to assigning a default role
like
editor now this was a crawl walk run
process we started out with a completely
manual task where we just copied output
out of the console we then experimented
with using Cloud functions to retrieve
the output and ultimately we landed on a
fully onboard a fully automated process
that ties into our Cloud onboarding
procedures another part of our security
strategy is to make the console read
only in production environments in our
Dev environments users can log into the
console they can man manipul manipulate
resources in production the console is
readon users can log in they can view
their resources but that's it the way we
accomplish locking down the console is
by creating a readon version of our
developer role and assigning that to
users in the production
environments there are times when break
Blass permission there are times when
elevated permissions might be needed
like during an issue in these cases we
have a break glass process where we can
assign elevated roles we do this with
conditional I am policies with a time
frame being the condition this will
allow the issue to be addressed and the
permissions will automatically be
removed when no longer
needed now that I've established how we
use IM am policies to meet our
requirement of Le lease privilege I'll
tell you about our next guardrail IAC
policies since we require all changes to
be code we could add a governance layer
that checks and validates all changes
before they're applied org policies are
at the end of the process and stop a
resource from being created our IAC
governance is at the beginning of the
process and performs checks before
resource creation ever starts this is
part of our defense and depth
strategy as I mentioned before we want
to shift feedback to earlier in the
process and inform developers early if
there is an issue so to help provide
that feedback we recreate org policy
constraints in this governance layer if
code that will violate violate an org
policy is submitted it will be caught
before being
applied and because we have the ability
to write custom policies we're not
limited to just the policy policies that
gcp provides any attribute that our I
pipeline outputs is something that we
can perform a check on and validate that
it meets our requirements if it does not
we'll notify the developer and block the
creation of these
resources I previously mentioned that we
don't use basic roles currently there's
no org policy that we could configure to
stop the assignment of these
roles so to compensate we have an i
policy that checks all I am bindings to
see if a basic Ro is being used if it
sees an assignment it will block the
chain and inform the user that they
cannot use this role this I governance
layer allows us to shift left by
blocking misconfigurations before they
ever happen and ensuring our resources
are created securely from the
start here's an example of all three of
the previous guard rails working
together we wanted to give the ability
for users to deploy load balancers but
we don't want them to expose those load
balancers to the internet the first
problem we faced was the I role for load
balancer creation is agnostic meaning
the same role lets you create internal
and external load balancers
so we gave users that role but we also
configured the load balancer org policy
to only allow internal load balancers to
be
created that worked great anytime a user
tries to deploy an external load
balancer the org policy stops
IT the next problem was that the org
policy stopped the deployment after the
code tries to execute and that could
cause an issue with deployments that
failure was in the middle of the
deployment process and left resources in
a bad State such as partially configured
and as you would expect that was a bad
experience for
developers we needed a way to validate
that the or policy constraint was met
before resource creation started so we
created an i policy to check to see if
external load balancers were being
provisioned if it was theier would get
feedback during the process that they
submitted the wrong load balancer and
they would not be able to move forward
with this
configuration by adding a check to the
beginning of the process we were able to
provide feedback early and guide the
developers to a secure deployment this
example showcases our defense in-depth
approach to the use of three distinct
security guard rail
controls looking forward we're excited
to leverage new security tooling from
gcp to strengthen our security posture a
couple of the tools we're excited for
are custom org policies which will allow
us to convert our IC policies to org
policies and strengthen our defense in-
depth approach and policy life cycle
management tooling to help ensure we
have a safe roll out of new policies
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be here and now here's Bach from
snap
thank you Matt for the intro and for
sharing with us Box's approach to
establishing secure access guard
rails all right good afternoon everyone
my name is bak bahamin and I am the
manager of snap's production security
team um we're a group of Engineers on a
mission to safeguard snap's production
infrastructure and provide its
developers with a secure environment to
deploy and host
Services snap's adoption of Google Cloud
goes back to our company comp's early
Beginnings the backend services for a
popular app Snapchat launched an app
engine over 11 years ago during my seven
years at the company I've had the
opportunity to witness the evolution of
our production infrastructure from a
monolithic app engine hosted service to
an expansive environment powered by a
diverse set of compute Network and data
resources today I'll be sharing with you
how snap approached this transition the
tools that our team developed to support
the company through this journey the
scale at which we operate and some of
the ways that we leverage in-house
development and Google Cloud provided
solutions to harden our infrastructure
and establish reliable access guard
rails at snap we strive to build
products that are smart kind and
creative and we wanted a access
management solution that was consistent
with these Core Company values
for a solution to be kind it needed to
promote developer agility and give our
Engineers the flexibility they needed to
iterate and innovate rapidly our desired
solution would therefore need to
delegate routine access
decisions um to the service teams and as
much as possible remove our team from
the developer request
path for a solution to be smart it would
need to continuously Drive the company
towards the security principle of of
lease
privilege where all approved permissions
match a recorded and valid business need
it would need to also provide us with
real-time visibility into employee and
service account permissions
ensure that all policy non-compliant
permissions were prevented and ensure
that all policy exceptions would be
ultimately funneled to our team for
proper review and
validation finally we needed a creative
approach to weave this n access
management framework across a production
infrastructure that was already serving
hundreds of millions of snapchatters
every
day said a little bit differently we
wanted a solution that would allow our
developer Community to retain a relative
level of autonomy but allow us to
enforce a number of security guard rails
as they explored new cloud services and
paradigms for this we built an internal
authorization management solution that
orchestrates permissions in across our
entire production
infrastructure this solution includes a
web portal that developers can navigate
to and where they can request a number
of predefined and custom roles in our
gcp
environment in the example depicted here
a snap developer is requesting object
viewer permissions on a gcp project when
requesting permissions employees can
elect for time bound or indefinite
access based on their needs and use
case once the request is submitted it is
automatically forwarded to Resource
owners or resource administrators for
approval at snap we have defined
resource administrators for each gcp
resource in our environment these admins
typically the service and project owners
themselves are responsible for
validating each request based on the
employees job role are um the requested
permissions the requested term and the
documented business
justification once the request is
approved our solution automatically
applies the appropriate gcp IM policies
in our
environment for short-term grants the
solution also automatically revokes
revokes the policy once the policy once
the approved term has
expired finally this solution maintains
authoritative controls over all of our
GCS gcp policies and any policy
configured outside of the solution is
automatically
revoked from an ergonomics perspective
the solution has scaled well and allowed
us to distribute validated authorization
controls across a large gcp footprint
more importantly it gave the company the
necessary flexibility to rapidly iterate
and overtime transition out of a single
glal app engine project and into the
service oriented and mesh architecture
that we operate in
today at present day our solution
handles hundreds of thousands of access
requests every year and allows the
company to seamlessly manage permissions
for tens of thousands of identities
across thousands of gcp projects gke
clusters and hundreds of thousands of
storage
resources next I'll cover how our team
deliver security guard rails across this
expansive
environment with such powerful
permissions extended to our resource
administrators we needed reliable guard
rails and mechanisms to prevent certain
actions that may contravene our security
and privacy policies here we enforced a
set of Google Cloud organization
policies like domain restricted sharing
which establish limits on who can access
our
resources we also apply additional or
policy constraints that prevent the
adoption of unapproved resources and
services in our Cloud
environment additional Google Cloud
controls such as VPC service controls
are used to cordon off sensitive
resources and prevent the data that they
store from being moved to lower trust
environments lastly we have built custom
orchestration services that block most
high-risk Cloud mutations for examples
these will repeal any firewall rule that
may inadvertently expose our internal
services to the
internet our second set of guard rail
allow us to regularly prune
over-provisioned roles and stale
policies stale permissions naturally
occur over time for example an engineer
may have acquired a set of permissions
while assigned to a specific initiative
but has since been reassigned to a
different
product leveraging gcps I am recommender
tool we are able to constantly surface
over provisioned rules and permissions
that are no longer in active
use based on on access activity over a
configurable Time window the IM
recommender provides either a replace or
remove Ro recommendation for all
principles that are not taking full
advantage of their existing gcp Ro
grants in the example here the
recommender service is letting us know
that our service account is no longer
using their storage object viewer role
on the project and that this policy can
safely be
revoked at snap we've built an internal
Ro removal service service that queries
the recommender apis and automatically
removes unnecessary permissions to
continuously drive us towards the
principle of lease
privilege staying true to our mission of
safeguarding snaps production
infrastructure we are continuously
evolving and looking for new
opportunities to establish reliable
access and policy guard
rails from gcp product perspective
here's what we're excited about next
we're excited to see custom organization
policies go ga soon as we plan to adopt
this product to help us enforce amongst
other things GK constraints associated
with CIS
benchmarks we're also excited about the
future of recommender tools on gcp since
we make heavy use of the IM recommender
today we're excited to see support for
additional products like GCS buckets and
big query data
sets in addition to I am recommender
we're also excited about similar
recommender capabilities for other
policy types such as organization
policies IM am deny and
others thank you for your time and the
privilege to speak with you here at next
2023 AE back to
you thank you Madden Bak uh for sharing
your approach to securing production
infrastructure on Google Cloud you've
now had a chance to hear both from um
box and from snap on their approach to
implementing security guard rails on gcp
you might have noticed that while their
intent and their security goals are
strongly aligned their approach the
individual approach differs slightly the
phase of where you are in your Cloud
Journey uh will impact the approach that
you adopt for implementing security
guard rails and gcp security guard rails
are flexible enough to meet you where
you are in that journey in the last few
minutes uh we wanted to share more
details about the future of security
guard rails in Google Cloud
as part of our upcoming road map we are
going to be focusing on three main
initiatives first we will be focused on
delivering new types of security guard
rails that are aimed at giving
administrators even more control to help
them better protect their principles
their resources and their data for
example we are working towards General
availability of custom Mar policy with
gke GCE and GCS and we will follow soon
after with other key gcp products such
as GCS we are also working on a new
control that will help uh administrators
apply guard rails on all the principles
that they manage this security control
will be able to enforce that any
principle uh irrespective of what
permissions and access they have from IM
policies will only have access to
resources within a specified authorized
boundary as defined by the
administrator second we will continue
investing in extending the functionality
of existing security controls we will
provide more flexible knobs for these
controls less restrictive limit ations
and more uniform support across the
entire Google Cloud ecosystem of
products and lastly we will continue
expanding our portfolio of life cycle
policy management tools we will add
uniform support for the tools that we
talked about like dry run recommender uh
analyzer across the entire security
guard rails tool set we will also extend
this tools to make it easier and safer
for you to deploy posture and policy
changes in your
environments to give you a flavor of
what is to come here's a brief demo of
Uh custom Mo policy that illustrates the
power of custom Mo policy and policy
life cycle
tooling consider back to the use case
where we wanted to deploy
uh GK clusters only with hardened and
trusted images to do this I'm going to
go ahead and create a custom Mo policy
here some something called gke binary
authoriz enable GK binary authorization
and the goal here would be to have it
act on the cluster resource type and
only for the create and update
operations uh looking through gke
documentation I've identified the knob
that I want to use here to enable this
card rail specifically binary
authorization like I mentioned and I'm
going to add that in here using cell
common expression language simple
condition where binary authorization
enabled equal to true then and only then
allow the constraint to be
created okay now that the constraint is
created we want to make sure that you
can safely roll this out in your
environments one of the first things
that is available to you as part of this
is something that we call policy
simulator which gives you the ability to
evaluate impact of these or policy
changes or policy changes on your
existing resources the first step here
is to define the scope of this policy
change uh in this example here I want to
make this policy change apply on my
entire
organization once I've defined the scope
I can now go ahead and initiate the
simulator which will check all of my
resources against this new constraint
that I have authored and generate a
report that looks something like
this here you can see the exact
constraint that you just authored with
the condition that you just um designed
uh for binary authorization checks you
can see all of the resources that would
be in violation of this constraint uh
with the full path making it easier for
you to understand what the net impact
would be of this uh change on your
organization as well as on um you know
your
resources you can also set this policy
in dryon mode essentially just like you
would uh modify an existing policy or
apply a new policy you set the rules you
set the conditions and instead of
setting the policy as live policy you
set it into a dry run mode as you can
see here now the dry run policy is in an
enforced State now let's say I go ahead
and create a cluster where with binary
authorization disabled now this this
this action will actually be permitted
however we will generate a log entry for
you with specific dry run metadata
tagging that will allow you to compare
the dry run result with the live result
and actually flag the uh resource or the
cluster that was created that is
offending this specific new constraint
that you're designing now that you're
confident with the constraint that you
have designed and you want to enforce it
this behaves exactly like your exist any
other policies that you have interacted
with before I'm adding a rule I'm set
setting this policy to enforce in my
organization layer as you can see here
this is an enforced state in your
organization now let's say I try and
create a new cluster with uh binary
authorization
disabled and as expected like with any
other orc policy this is a preventive
guard rail this will action will not be
permitted it will generate an error that
says your your your uh resource action
violates this new arc policy that you're
uh this AR policy that you've created
and you know you you can no longer
proceed and this is exactly as we
intend with that uh we have reached the
end of this session I wanted to extend a
massive thank you to Matt and babach and
their teams for the continued great
partnership with gcp uh for defining the
future of security guard
rails